Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to...  a vlog
I know, I know, pretty goddamn terrible. And don't worry!
This isn't gonna be the only video today.
But I realized that with my new schedule
I don't often have an opportunity to just talk to you guys
And I-I miss out on that- I mean I want to do more live streams and stuff like that, too.
In addition to this new schedule like I've been really happy with it, but also
It's freed up a lot of time to not only
Pursue things that I want to do in terms of music and other hobbies that I have but it also frees up some time
To do more live streams
But that's not the point of this video, the main point of this video is because I wanted to talk to you guys about
PAX, AND the Markiplier calendar
Number one:
We actually raised a lot more money than we thought we did. At the end of the campaign the website said that
we raised about three hundred and eighty two thousand three hundred and eighty-five dollars ($382,385)
the actual amount raised is a lot higher than that. Because with more
calendars sold, the production costs go down, and that means more money is able to go for charity. I'm being
told, I haven't gotten a clear number yet
because they still have to ship it to me so that I can hand sign every one of those,
But they have to ship it to me
and then I have to ship it back and then they have to ship it out to everybody and that's just more cost for
shipping, but it shouldn't be too much more
But what I'm being told is that the actual number is around half a million dollars raised for the Cancer
Research Institute. And I wanted to tell you guys that because I'm incredibly proud of that number! Like that's
an astonishingly huge number for charity! It's so big in fact... It is a NEW
RECORD! That's something that you should be incredibly proud about!
that is a NEW FUCKING RECORD and that comes just after we did
one in November where, with the help of
someone else, with an anonymous donor for Save the Children, we raised over four hundred
thousand dollars for charity
But this is all you guys! This is all you guys buying this tasteful nudes calendar to see my butt
plastered across a few months, and we raised almost half a million dollars for charity
That's incredible!! So I just wanted to say thank you. You know.
Thank you guys so much for supporting this WEIRD way of doing charity for celebrating 20 million subscribers
And also accepting this new weird way that I want to do videos. And in all honesty, it's not that weird,
It's just one longer or more dense video a day and, it's been a lot of fun
you know I've been very happy with creating things just the past few weeks that I've had and
admittedly I've been doing mostly gaming stuff because with the 20 million subscriber calendar and with going
to PAX, I haven't had time to make a lot of live-action goofs
But I've got...
tons of ideas
that I want to implement. Some of them involve a paintball gun and I have to go get a paintball gun and
then I think Tyler's gonna have to shoot me with it
You're gonna see! It's not just me punishing myself for the sake of being punishment.
I've got an idea for it. But don't-
Don't worry about it! Anyway. It's it's just been it's it's a lot of fun
It's been a lot of fun, I've been really happy about it.
I'm just excited for the future, and we just came back from PAX and I was able to hang out with my friends
again I was able to see people that I haven't seen in a long time
And we were able to talk about the future, we were able to talk about things that weren't just video making, and
you know...I
you know I'm just really happy.
I-I think that's shown in the videos that I've been making but I think you guys can see it
And I've just been really happy, and now that I'm back and the only thing I have to look forward to in the next
trip is Wade's wedding! Which it's just a crazy thing to even think about!
Congratulations Wade! He's gonna get married in MAY!
But it's.. you know, It's.. yeah. There's a lot of things to look forward to this year,
And there's a lot of things that I've been able to look forward to and
Yeah, it's been good.
Anyway, that's all I wanted to say I've got another quick video that I'm gonna be putting out today, something that... I've been
addicted to Fortnite and I've been playing it on my own, uh. A lot
I mean, pretty much everybody in the world is addicted to Fortnite now, and I've never been one to play it a lot.
Um. But I've been playing it on my own
And I haven't been streaming it just because, like I'm not good enough to- I'm not good enough
I don't think I'm good enough to compete. I was playing with Tyler yesterday, and
We were just blowing each other up in high explosive mode, and laughing our ASSES off, and you know it's
been fun. Anyway. I'll stop rambling I'll get out of here quick. I just wanted to make a quick update video for
you guys and just... thanks
Thanks for being there with me. You know, for me. You know. Thanks for being here with me. You know
Thanks for sticking by me, and thanks for believing in me.
Those are the most important things that I could ever ask for and you guys have
delivered in more ways than I ever could have imagined so thanks, anyway!
I'll let you go, take care of yourselves. Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you...
In the next video. BUH-BYE!!!